[Music]
anybody here fly to united airlines
yeah you fly whatever flight i can get
yeah same okay irrelevant question
almost but a woman
in the u.s almost traveling on a united
airlines flight
awoke to find another passenger
allegedly fondling her breast
what just a random yeah you know i heard
this shit's common like um like if you
take a greyhound bus or if you take like
any like flights or whatever and then
like there's a pervert next to you you
[ __ ] knock out you wake up and
they're just like on you and [ __ ] that's
[ __ ] crazy that's [ __ ] it's like
for me it's like
there have to be dumb like do you think
that they're not going to wake up and
like look at you and be like even if my
neighbor was like had a bomb [ __ ]
cheesecake right and i wake up and i'm
like sleeping
i still wouldn't get the [ __ ]
cheesecake that's that's theirs that's
because you're not a criminal yeah yeah
like
but apparently you're trying to
empathize with him oh okay i'm trying to
put myself in a situation where that's
possible
you know like people don't expect to
wake up being fondled and [ __ ] so like
you know how like the fight or flight
right some people just freeze up and
[ __ ] so like uh apparently these [ __ ]
that do it they get more and more bold
because
that's not the i bet you that's not the
[ __ ] first time this guy followed the
woman right so like the first time
he didn't get in trouble for it maybe he
was just like
i could do it again
that's crazy though
court documents say the woman had been
traveling from las vegas to washington
when she fell asleep on the flight she
then woke up to find ivan lopez jr who's
26 years old rubbing her right breast
with prosecutors saying she shouted get
away from me
lopez jr then got up and went to the
back of the plane and admitted to a
flight attendant that he had sexually
assaulted the woman sitting next to him
the flight attendant immediately moved
him from the 12th row to the 21st row in
order to keep him away from the female
passenger
where's the air market he just made him
change seats well i mean you're already
in the air like what else can you
[ __ ] duct tape that fool
oh remember when they duct taped that
guy when he was being there they [ __ ]
slammed him on the floor or some sort of
[ __ ] zip tie or [ __ ] yeah dude
i wonder if there's like protocol that
uh like uh uh you know uh what are they
called the [ __ ] agents on the planes
they're marshalls
unless it's like like a terrorist attack
yeah they're like sorry she's the air
marshal in this man
he's the air
the whole time flight is just all air
marshals
they later they find guns they all pull
out a badge they're trying to stay
undercover they find out they're both
air marshals oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
what movie was that where uh was it
bridesmaids yeah you air marshall
yeah so when the passenger opened her
eyes she alleged uh allegedly observed
lopez leaning over her and his right
hand was placed on her right breast the
passenger allegedly right on right yeah
it's one of these
oh like this yeah that's my left though
then it's either this or let's say you
go grab me like that's that
oh
that's a that's a long reach because
it's not one of those like it's not like
that
it's a bat
or it's a bat like it's it's a parent
so the lopez jr now faces a charge of
abusive sexual contact aboard an
aircraft and if convicted could be
jailed for up to two years
and ain't probably gonna go to jail i
feel like he's they don't [ __ ] what
do you think it would be a more
appropriate punishment for something
like that cut his hands oh poetry let's
get poetic punishments for this minus
one hand oh he has to listen to slam
poetry 24 hours a day wow he went
literal with the poetry
and he's like
and specifically it has to be women
empowerment feminism everything that he
violated yeah maybe he like loses his
hand but then he also gets like a you
know prosthetic breast like attached to
his forehead like a like a scarlet
letter that's a good idea
i like that or you put one under his
chest you triple tit you put up a triple
tip but it's big enough where it sticks
out wherever you go so everyone's gonna
be like yo
it's gotta be seen though like in
glorious bastards because otherwise
he'll just maybe just fondle himself and
be satisfied yeah yeah oh yeah that's
true
a little nicky is a titty yeah a little
[ __ ]
double tits
it's gotta be somewhere he can't hide
you know he has to ride in the back of
the cargo plane for the rest of his life
and the the cargo air planes if he wants
to travel yeah cause that stuff is weird
it's like what do you do in that
situation like how do we stop this from
happening more often i think i think
chopping the hand off is pretty sad i
wonder i wonder if he does it because
the the kink is getting found like he's
getting it yeah probably
you know it's like oh my god and he's
like oh no i did a bad thing
excuse me
well does that put him on the sex he's
not on the sex offenders registry for
that or like the no flight list or maybe
he was in international water no i'm
just kidding i don't know i think you
get all of the above you get all you
both no fly list anymore
you touch someone's breast on a flight
and they're sleeping you can't fly
anymore
yeah like it like like an airplane where
they beat the show
whenever it involves a woman i feel like
it it makes them it makes they like it
like they want to get touched by women
get attent get a reaction like it has to
be what they don't want i think that's
punishment all the guys get up every
[ __ ] is that song
yeah but he can only grab man titties
for two years yeah oh okay
what about rehabilitation where like
let's say all the aisle seats of uh of
an airplane are just like hot mannequin
chicks and then if you're a registered
sex offender that's the middle row you
get to
you get to buy your seat so then at
least you get to like
kind of slowly wean off of it your
empathy game is real strong on this
episode this is the rehabilitation
perspective that's kind of fire i like
the i like the scandinavian coaches
probably have positive i mean
i like that i think what has to happen
same setup
we put electrodes on his dick
on his nose and his ears right
because it conducts electricity better
when it goes from here to this chakra
okay okay so every time he hogs
every time he hawks like that like
operations yeah it goes
and he gets it's like shocked there oh
hell yeah but then at some point you
probably like that so then he'll just
keep
you know you know the you know the
[ __ ] giant dudes who do the slap
contest yeah a bunch of those guys but
they all like wear wigs and they all
stand on line and then he has to touch
their boob one time and then he has to
get slapped by them yeah just be the
fluffer for those events
oh
they should just like warm up
or we could skip all those processes and
then after he grabs the boob and he goes
and he says oh yeah i did it
throw him out the plane just like that
like that oh that's a good idea easy
simple efficient probably over water
yeah they went vegas
he just soars closer to her
you think
other way around it like they're like
women out there that are just you know
groping man
yeah but like you know in the same i
mean this seems so well you know it just
seems so like uh i guess
it feels one-sided i think groping is
probably like
substantially you know over not equal
yeah you know what i mean like it it's
probably heavily represented by men like
if i wore tight sweatpants and then i
put like a thing of salami and i'm just
like sitting in the aisle i'm over here
like i don't know if any chicks are like
oh yeah there's one
[ __ ] ground yeah i'll be panicking
like damn eat that kind of if we're in a
three aisle seat i'll ask the girl next
to him like you gonna hit it or am i
gonna touch it
you're gonna do it
what's a sexual harassment direct
detective
he's going undercover
and he's a stingy
i hope no women touches me
or or he puts a camera in the salami
piece yeah so when girls look down
they're like excuse me i saw you look at
my penis how dare you yeah you [ __ ] his
ass up that's what you do he's just got
like high-tech glue there so if you
touch it your hand's stuck
you're just out there to stop a crime
that never occurs
i think there should be growth patrol
you know like there's got to be some
kind of um
specific squad because you know we have
so many other squads like the dea like
hell's angels
that's illegal yeah
official retainer official
but like you know we have departments of
like oh this one's for [ __ ] human
trafficking yeah atf yeah we need we
need grope patrol you know like so like
because that shit's happening and then
like you know um right now cops can't
keep them in jail like they catch them
but they're not doing [ __ ] because it's
like [ __ ] d.a yeah
and this is happening in a lot of cities
where like dudes are just out there like
groping women all day and they're like
really i don't have to get in trouble
like oh yeah what's stopping them
because unfortunately they're the ones
that like women are the ones that get
the
[ __ ] [ __ ] out of the stick yeah
they're the ones that are have to pay
for it you know back in uh 2001 i was at
the third street promenade santa monica
and there was a guy you know like people
watch those like little street
performances and they get in crowds
every time those happen like sometimes
there's a dude that's like getting real
close to people kind of like humping
their asses and [ __ ]
this guy was um i was there with my ex
and her friends and this guy started
doing it to them like when i was in the
store and then i came back out and my ex
was like yeah this guy was like hopping
on on my friends and stuff
and i was like which which [ __ ] guy
is it and this is my like [ __ ] tough
moment so then i go to his back and i i
go right up on his ass i like how you
tough and i'm just like i'm [ __ ] like
my dick is like in his ass and then he's
just like yo what's your problem and i
just went
and it just went
his hat came up yeah
you hum
he just humped his [ __ ] so hard that he
fell forward and he knew that he was
caught for that [ __ ] everybody was
looking at that's tight and they were
just like everyone's like yeah
you can get that guy and then ryan went
to jail
and that's why i'm on the sex offenders
list
[Laughter]
i like how you got him back you get
because because you can't you can't like
fight him or else it's assault
no one proved that he actually did that
it's like i would have just assaulted
him you're smart that is smart though
well i think because because he because
no he'll know that like oh [ __ ] that's
just they knew they know what i'm doing
yeah
bart's uh dog tyson he hunt my leg the
first time i met him and i said oh yeah
bro and i [ __ ] hump the [ __ ] out of
him yeah i stopped after that huh yeah
oh damn you gotta show him who's boss
bro yeah
[Music]
[Music]
you